The Arctic is warming up
to four times faster
than the rest of the world.
Ice caps are melting and
sea ice is retreating,
changing the weather and
disrupting marine life.
To protect these polar ecosystems,
we need to understand them.
And no one knows the Arctic
as well as the indigenous
communities that live here.
Greenland is the world's
largest island.
It is one of the most extreme
environments on Earth
where polar night or
24 hour daylight
can last for months
and temperatures can
reach -50.
Inuit have thrived here since
time immemorial.
But the Arctic is changing,
and it's happening in mere decades.
Indigenous peoples of the far north
have been adapting to
change for millennia.
A new generation of Greenlanders
is combining science and
traditional knowledge
and in the process, reframing
perceptions of the Arctic.
In Greenland, journalists and scientists
come for one thing,
for climate change.
How do you see that as a Greenlander?
There's a very powerful narrative
around the Arctic these days
and Arctic indigenous peoples,
that we are the place
of climate change.
But we've lived here on these lands
for thousands of years
and there's a lot more to us
than climate change.
What indigenous scientists can do
is to bridge some of that gap.
As a microbiologist I'm interested
in understanding
how being in nature, eating from
nature impacts us through
connecting us to the microbiology
of our environment.
Microbial species outnumber the
stars in our galaxy,
and they impact every living
thing on earth,
including Arctic biomes.
What we're looking at here
is the downstream effect
of nutrients like phosphate,
silicate and nitrogen.
how they affect the fjord systems
out there
specifically the phytoplankton.
So this is a land-terminating
glacier, feeding in via rivers.
And so what's the difference between
a marine-terminating glacier
and a land-terminating one?
The marine-terminating glacier
creates an upwelling effect
on nutrients,
and these nutrients spike the
biological production
in the fjords.
Well, when they retreat back, we lose
part of the microscopic plankton
and they are in turn food
for higher organisms
like whales, for instance.
It's all connected, right?
In Kalaallisut, we have this incredibly
meaningful word, Sila.
Sila means the weather,
it means consciousness,
it means the spirit,
it means outside.
We're not separate from nature.
When our minds are well, when the
Sila inside of us is well,
we can treat our environment well.
Right now, my work is very much
focused on building
the Sila biology program.
We're going to be outside a lot like,
that supports mental health
but it's also an excellent way
of learning biology.
When we eat from nature, when what
we wear comes from nature.
We are conscious that what we do
has consequences.
People assume that it will have a
really strong smell,
but it's not strong, it's just
very particular.
It's very particular to iginneq.
I'm currently so excited that I can't even
think, I'm just in eating mode.
My biggest hope is that we'll have
Indigenous students
coming out of this program who can use
the skills that they've learned
to make a difference for
their communities.
Arctic peoples are uniquely placed to
understand what is happening here
and what it means to heal our
relationship with nature.
We just need to be willing to
listen and to learn.
Prada group and IOC/UNESCO
launched SEA BEYOND
to promote ocean education
around the world.
SEA BEYOND represents Prada Group's
long-term commitment
to supporting educational programs
that connect
the younger generation with
marine ecosystems.
That's why Prada is donating
one percent of profits
from its Re-Nylon collection to generate
innovative approaches,
science-based solutions and
humanitarian projects
that address the global challenges
facing our ocean.